we are following developing news
overnight five homes have been destroyed
after a fire
several people now this morning they
don't have a place to go they are
homeless after this fire this is in the
southeast part of the valley
bianca holman live this morning at a
mobile home park near warm springs and
east lake mead bianca
good morning john and alex so this fire
started around 11 last night right down
this street
and we've seen the fire crews leave and
also the officers that were on scene
kind of helping contain this situation
overnight so
the hot spots have been contained and
the emergency crews have left right now
we're told it started in one mobile home
and it was the wind
that caused the flames to spread
destroying at least five
other homes nearby police clark county
and henderson fire departments rushed in
to rescue people it was a scary moment
for residents living in the neighborhood
as they
sought shelter at the nearby elementary
school across the street
the police were very good the fire fire
department was very good to get us out
of here
they cut a hole in the fence for all of
us to get out in the desert area so
all they could do is say a prayer you
know i'm saying and hope hopefully
everything works out
and you can even hear the wind and just
how strong it was
in as we spoke with one of the folks who
lived here in this
neighborhood and witnessed the fire and
the cause of the fire is under
investigation so there is the red cross
and the salvation army that is here to
help those folks who were displaced
after this situation
and also those who were walking back to
their homes told us that
they were told that the power is going
to be out for at least or could be up to
48 hours
but there is a nearby heritage senior
center that will have air conditioning
so those folks once they get back home
if they'd like they can go over there
to cool off because the fire the power
will be out for some time
reporting live down here in the
southeast part of the valley bianca
holman 8 news now